alors laetitia l'idée alors là c'est
hyper chaud sans déconner la led de
laëtitia à ce temps là ça ce temps se
passait son temps et que ton sérieux
string à une arbalète dedans laëticia
hallyday a répondu à david hallyday et
laura smet qui avait demandé un droit de
regard sur l'album posthume de leur père
le journal le point de pologne qui
pointent très sérieux oui j'aime
beaucoup le point je le lis parfois a
dévoilé la réponse de l'epo johnny si à
chaque fois de vue chez le dentiste
laura david voici la réponse de laëtitia
c'est avec beaucoup de surprise que
j'accuse réception de votre lettre
cette requête assortie d'un délai de 48
heures pour s'exécuter prend le ton
d'une mise en demeure
je n'entends pas je n'entends pas
accéder à cette injonction qui n'est pas
fondée l'intégralité des droits
d'auteurs et d'artistes interprètes de
mon époux m'a été dévolue au terme de
ses dernières volontés
il m'appartient donc seul de faire
respecter le droit moral de mont nébo
alors là ça ce ton de ouf
il perd le blog de jean marc morandini a
révélé en exclusivité le communiqué de m
roland perez l'avocat de sylvie vartan
l'ex de johnny et donc la mère de david
et confirme confirme que la moitié de la
maison attribué à david avait bien été
donnée par sylvie vartan et non pas par
johnny hallyday par johnny est vraiment
dans ce cas le point qui a publié le
testament manuscrit de johnny hallyday
qui est à l'origine de la guerre des
camps qui oppose laetitia à david et
laura y dans ce testament rédigé le 3
avril 2014 à marnes-la-coquette johnny
déclare ceci est mon testament qui
révoque toutes dispositions antérieures
je soussigné jean philippe smet entend
légué l'intégralité de ma succession à
mon épouse laeticia marie-christine
boudou voilà cette dernière recevra donc
conformément à la loi californienne
l'ensemble de mes biens et ce compris la
totalité de mes droits artistiques
il n'ya pas donc voilà il n'y a pas
vraiment de alors et donc laetitia la
mine de rien oui je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez mais ccc johnny c'est les
volontés de johnny mine de rien moi je
prend la défense de deux personnes sur
la jolie je connais les chevaux des
personnes ni des fachos et david qui est
très sympa mais voilà mais mine de rien
elle sait c'est johnny qui tive celui ci
parce qu'on peut lui reprocher si on a
envie des choses qu'on peut pas lui
reprocher de se défendre quand même
attaqué de toutes parts c'est normal
qu'elle fasse une lettre a pu dicter par
son avocat aussi parce que les termes
sont très précis dans
de la procédure juridique va être
entamée mais c'est normal qu'elle se
défend elle peut pas non plus prendre et
ombres ou comme ça sourire agathe ah oui
moi j'en peux plus de cette histoire je
trouve que ça devient gênant malsain
indécent je pense que il se passer à une
succession de mensonges le
rebondissement de kouba de l'est qui se
tirent dessus fin cela n'a pu se faire
une bonne année à tous bien profiter ça
a plu à beaucoup de monde personne
on l'a on la regarde et on l'avait
d'abord ça continue de passionner les
jambes à huy les médias n'en parleraient
pas autant les jo a lancé la figure donc
voilà ça continue d'être une sorte de
feuilleton est ce que vous pensez des
des mois je suis choqué pourquoi revue
choqué par laetitia choke et de cette
lettre je le dis je trouve que cette
lettre elle est glacial ll faut 10
aspect alors là oui mais ça fait ça fait
peur il ya aucun affecte leur déclara
des chaleureuses nous avons maintenant
mais moi franchement à l'aide je suis
choqué je trouve que on ne peut pas
écrire ça alors à et adapte un mois il
faisait trop violent où les gens mine de
rien ils pensent qu'à une chose aussi
c'est johnny c'est sur le thème johnnie
to a eu tout bon début de journée on n'a
pas envie on dit maintenant parle que de
ça le pauvre n'a pas envie que johnny
ait fait ça en fait c'est ça le problème
c'est pour ça que ça nous intéresse
parce que la wii personne ne soit lésé
on a grandi avec david moyes jeunes
adorent david c'est un mec adorable
c'est un mec extraordinaire pourquoi
david travaille pas sur l'album posthume
c'est quand même hallucinant on a envie
qui travaillent dessus années écrit le
plus bel album de johnny 100% ça a été
le plus gros succès de sa carrière
mais pourquoi il écartait moi j'ai envie
qu'il a fait son choix mais on n'a pas
envie non thomas bernhard êtes vous êtes
très proche de la famille oui mais moi
je trouve ça franchement d'une profonde
tristesse
c'est vrai c'est un peu élitiste je
pense que la belle se défend laëtitia
mais moi il est vrai que comme en direct
c'est même plus une question d'argent
comment un papa vieillit venir
déshériter ses enfants selon non c'est
pas possible ça me change n'ont servi
zone euro dans la lettre a tenté des
choses avancent
non mais alors c'est énorme et très peu
la donne et très peu comme un papa
richard dit bah oui mais bon alors pour
numéro un il faut respecter la volonté
d'un mort oui point numéro 1 maintenant
une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est que le
début parce qu'effectivement mais voyez
moi david hénot race et je pense qu'ils
se battent pas forcément pour lowe's et
parce que vous verrez qu'au final le
veil n'aura pas tant que ça quand tu es
donc et tous les comptes mais je
comprends très bien que le droit moral
souhaité qu'il soit déchu de ce droit
moral
c'est terrible parce que effectivement
dans une famille c'est ça qui va compter
c'est l'héritage culturel de johnny est
là pour le coup je comprends pied un
problème sur le fond l'oseille mais vrai
que l'original mais ferrer et laeticia
hallyday a eu le soutien d'une personne
très importante qui l'a soutenu je vous
dirai dans un instant tu maintenant
cesser cette fois je ne sais pas bien ce
que tu dis j'en faisais moi ou sèches
bluetooth promet d'une quand d'une
candeur pardon mais consternante c'est
une famille qui a toujours vécu devant
la télévision et devant les médias donc
la suite posthume après la mort de
johnny ça continue mais elle est votre
adhésion la réponse de laëtitia susan
moi moi je la trouve évidemment très dur
et placé david et laura comme des gens
exclusivement intéressé c'est tout ça
profondément injuste pour des gens qui
souffrent ne fait plus de trente ans
aussi battue elle fait tout pour se
faire détester et elles y arrivent
parfaitement
c'est fou cette lettre faut quand même
pas oublier malgré tout qu'elle est
arrivée dans la vie du chanteur il avait
déjà 53 ans était pas non plus n'était
pas là pardon il avait déjà une carrière
en a 58 non vieux voilà je ne comprends
pas qu'elle n'est pas l'intelligence de
dire de toute manière ces deux filles
auront déjà beaucoup d'argent essayons
de trouver un accord lorsque oui
effectivement ce qu'a fait johnny c'est
pas correct qu'elles trouvent un accord
elle vérifie ça leur permet comme ça
ils en ont parlé de vous les deux avants
oui c'est johnny l1 voilà donc bah c'est
sûr donc chacun présente écoute des de
la position à chaque arrêt va lever le
poing johnny du joueur pourrait donc
c'est vrai que là ça se tend de plus en
plus on vous donnera je suis désolé
laura et david allait ou non pas fini il
faut se dire regarde a pour des mois et
des mois mais nous avions fini la saison
toutes vers dingle
ça vaut le coup d'oeil